this notice tells you that your landlord
requires possession of your home
sarah is facing eviction and it's
through no fault of her own her landlady
wants the house back and she's asked her
to leave if you do not leave your home
by the date given in section two your
landlord may apply to the court for an
order requiring you to give up
possession my understanding is it will
be either a hostel or shared
accommodation or temporary housing i am
looking at other private rented the
rental charges have gone up around 12 in
this area in the last 18 months and they
were already high so that's priced me
and people like me out completely really
during the pandemic there was a ban on
evictions but that was lifted last
summer
now they're back
since then more than a thousand tenants
have been evicted from homes owned or
managed by councils in britain according
to figures obtained by sky news that's
nearly four households each day
and more than fourteen thousand
landlords started court proceedings to
evict tenants from their own properties
between october and december last year
and the cost of living crisis threatens
to make many more tenants homeless
so what we have here is a map of leads
and what it shows is where all our money
buddies are so each of those pins tells
you where an advisor is that is going to
help a client out of debt
this charity in leeds is seeing a sharp
rise in calls from people struggling to
make ends meet including in areas that
have never previously needed help and
this is probably as as good an
illustration as ever of how the cost of
living crisis can spread
i think it's a i think it's a really
good way of putting it because that's a
good visual representation of how it's
spreading it's a it's a cancer that's
now bubbling through to so many areas
that thought i'm immune we've never been
as busy it's record levels let's put it
that way
the government says it's going to help
80 percent of households will get a 150
pound council tax rebate and all
families will get a 200 pound loan to
help with electricity bills
65 million pounds has already been given
to councils in england to help
vulnerable renters
jade is a debt advisor and she's seeing
up close the impact that the cost of
living crisis is having
do you think that we're going to see a
rise in evictions primarily because
people are
struggling with their utility bills and
struggling to pay for their rent yeah
it's making that decision what what do i
pay do i pay the rent do i pay for food
or do i put the heating on what do i do
the income that they get just doesn't
cover everything
do you mind if we keep our shoes on
sarah has been desperately looking for a
new home because of the way things are
the way we've literally got no time to
make a decision
because i know that there'll be other
people probably already viewed and will
be viewing later today it's good at the
moment it's just affordability at this
stage
a few days later sarah found a new home
to rent
but with the lifting of eviction bans
and the spiraling cost of living renters
face uncertain times ahead nick martin
sky news